well it's interesting
so it's it's uh this is the the
challenge is
okay the job can be automated yep and
then the next question is should it be
automated yep and if you want to make
more money that answer is usually yes
but i think about um so my brother lives
in new jersey now just moved to new
jersey from manhattan
and
in new jersey you're not allowed to pump
your own gas
you have to
let someone pump it for you
yeah and it's a i mean straight up job
creation program by the state of new
jersey and wildly popular because
frankly it's a mild convenience
it's actually something and some days
it's a major convenience if it's cold or
raining there's someone
you legally cannot pump your own gas in
new jersey quick question i'm always
confused are you supposed to tip them oh
you're not allowed to tip them or you're
i mean you're allowed to but it's very
very frowned upon because i get paid
decently well um
do you like this it's a good paying job
it's good wages i think i imagine decent
benefits because it's basically a
government jobs program
i
have never been a huge fan of government
jobs programs i think it's this is a
good like private version of it because
the
the government says you have to
you have to have someone pump the gas
and you have to pay them i'm not sure
the actual legality of it but they have
to be paid a certain amount
um but then the
gas stations themselves administer that
so it's not the government creating the
job itself it's they set the policy for
the private companies to create the job
um
look you can debate this back and forth
but the reality is it's employing a good
number of people and people need stuff
to do
um so that's like the hardest part right
like i totally big believer in like we
should automate automated automate but
then we gotta give people other things
to do exactly
uh anyway so
you go you work at all the you see this
firsthand
um
was the internship paid or was it like
college credit type deal it was paid
that's yeah aldi pays well another
another reason well it's hard because
there's it's they tell you to you got to
get experience but in order to get
experience you have to you know get
hired you have to have experience um
that's crazy i'll never forget all right
quick story i am my i went to uh i went
to duke university in north carolina by
the way final four week
here we go let's go duke um
i usually piss off half the room you
know duke there's plenty of duke
people hate duke like i hate the
patriots and i very much understand
because i hate patriots uh
but we don't cheat for the record um
okay
the
when i was um
a sophomore i dated a girl who was a
freshman and
she
her dad worked in finance gotcha and so
i remember i was a sophomore looking for
the big deal was like if you get a
sophomore internship because no one ever
hired freshman in college like that's
where you had to work forever big [ __ ]
but if you get a sophomore internship is
big deal it's like goldman sachs had
their sophomore program
and they were like a couple banks had
sophomore programs most internships were
for juniors um juniors
you you know you interview throughout
junior in the fall in the spring and
then you get your
summer internship um and somebody's
internship paid like out the ass like
you're getting paid a hundred grand for
a summer and i was like and what yeah
like 70 to 100 000 like and live in new
york i always think and i'm like brother
this is life-changing money for where i
was come from um
watching anyone yeah that's pretty
life-changing so i was like trying to
get one of these jobs but if you get one
as a sophomore and then if you get one
as a sophomore your game you're
guaranteed to get one as a junior
because you have something on your
resume most people have anything on
their ball effect so i remember
like getting my girlfriend helped me
with my resume
and
my resume was i was a lifeguard
for a summer every summer since i like
was 16 like i could in high school and i
worked at chili's
that was my resume and
i mean you know i had like i had a
resume to get into college whatever were
you at chili's were you like i was the
host
i love that job i mean i i can't say i
loved it but i agree restaurant jobs
everyone needs to have one at one point
oh yeah that's i learned a lot and like
it was um not great because the town
people i saw in town would come in and
see me there and like
really doing well zach huh like oh no
offense anyway so um
i was a host of chili's yep um
but uh
and her resume as a freshman was like
50x better than mine because when she
was a senior in high school she interned
at one of her dad's friends hedge fund
oh gosh and knew all the financial terms
and this sort of thing so she got one of
those sophomore internships so she got a
better internship as a sophomore than i
got
uh or sorry better internship for
herself as a senior in high school than
i could get as a sophomore in college
yeah um and this is like the kind of leg
up stuff that i learned pretty quickly
um
and so how i got my experience this is
like the bs where i was a lifeguard at
the pool i was a pool manager
but every morning
i had a
uh like a fi like a friend of a friend's
financial advisor like let me come in
and like literally stuff envelopes every
day and sit in like the financial office
of smith barney um did i learn some
stuff kind of but
i got to put on my resume like morgan
stanley smith barney wherever the heck
they were there yeah just the name and
that helped me get my foot in the door
and it's
and i had to work i'd work for free um
and he was nice he gave me some cash
under the table not a ton but like he
like but like he legally couldn't pay me
like from there they wouldn't do intern
so he paid me like out of the kind of
heart just and he wasn't a ton but it
was enough to have some spending money
whatever but um that's the game right
and it's awful um
and wait clarify why couldn't they pay
like they just didn't pay interest so
they i mean they had like a formal
internship program but they did not have
a budget for like the west hartford
elmwood branch of
connecticut wherever i was like yeah for
their internship and by the way i didn't
deserve that money i felt like i was
getting
a charity handout because i did nothing
for him like i did
your time yeah i gave my time yes but i
didn't help i literally just got paid to
learn which is um and i wasn't there
wasn't like a full-time job opportunity
there in the short run
um so this is what's hard like um kids
need to get that experience but it's
investment of the company to to do that
um
so
have your
this is actually where i'm going with
this
peers you know or the younger generation
let's call it gen z
uh as i catch all of like everybody
around this are they now focused instead
of like that like bs
experience to put on a resume are they
more focused on i'd rather be
a youtube content creator maybe get paid
a little bit that way or would i rather
be a
influencer or get into web 3 and make an
nftr project or something like that
that's a little lower upfront cost like
what
have you seen
in terms of that experience check the
box thing from young people yeah i mean
i don't think it's
all or nothing towards either one so i
mean you're seeing with uh high
schoolers stay more extracurriculars
than ever before like in terms of they
need to like deck out yeah deck out
there
the burnout is crazy amongst young kids
in terms of what they're
kind of experiencing the pressures in
order to get into college which is
just crazy but i mean you're definitely
seeing in the back of everyone's minds
even those people with full-time jobs
today everyone at the end of the day i
don't think i think people
align gen z with a want for
entrepreneurship but at the end of the
day i think the reality is people just
want autonomy and not maybe to have a an
entity over them 24 7.
so you're seeing like in the back of
people's minds yes when you have every
day in your face these content creators
and they have this clear autonomy within
their lifestyle that's in the back of
your mind and you're maybe aspiring to
that a little bit in different ways but
um
i think more so you see this amongst
young boys and like their role models of
whether it's elon musk or whether it's
the garyvees and mr beast and the logan
pauls of the world
you're kind of seeing them make harsher
decisions in regards to
yeah
dropping everything and trying to go
full into something to a decision like
content creation while girls usually
kind of
what i've seen are more so pursuing
those types of things on the side from
this is a really good point because
trying to think so i was growing growing
up
you know who your role who are my role
models right ending up thinking like or
who are my friends role models right so
you have like
athletes you're celebrities and athletes
as everybody right but then
for those in in some form of like
you know who are blessed enough to have
perspective on where they want to go
with their career what they want to do
then you start but it was
your steve jobs is your bill gates is
your it wasn't they weren't like
they weren't talking heads per se they
were just kind of figments and frankly
what they were like
obviously brilliant in um builders but
they were there was some form of
institutionalization around these names
yes um
and you're warren buffett's your um
these types and
there was
or even like for me my this is like was
a very sad day when he ended up being a
pervert but uh matt lauer was a huge
like oh gosh i forgot about that
situation i i felt like i lost like a
i don't know what that like
yes like i i really want to be matt
lauer growing up now i've learned that
that lifestyle is awful and like i've
lost my passion for wanting to be
hosting the today show four a.m mornings
yeah like oh man um
but
um but i mean matt or katie couric and
those al roker like they're creatures of
an institutional establishment of a
corporate america had a clear journey
right and they clearly worked their way
up and those that was a thing when i was
growing up that was like you could work
your way up a certain way and now
the role models for kids to your point
is that they're
they buck the trend
they if gary vaynerchuk gets aaron paul
where they're like uh they did something
crazy and then they built a platform out
of it and
the work your way up
uh buy your time
earn learn your skills earn your keep
your time will come mentality is now
make it now i'm famous instantly
uh you know and then you now have like
olivia rodriguez a high schooler writes
oh no don't get wrong she's a
world-class talent that's different but
it's famous now right
um
does that pressure hit
your generation and by the numbers it
seems to hit boys more than girls now
yeah well i mean olivia rodriguez that's
cut that stuff's always been prevalent
because that's just like child star she
was like
i mean she's well that's a bad example
yeah she is exceptional talent yeah but
people so
for example yeah we were saying like
elon musk he more so falls into like the
steve jobs warren buffett and was yeah
within the systems and establishments
and um obviously obviously he had
success young but still working within
this yeah he built his company from the
ground up and still does oh yeah
but um
so when we're seeing these other people
gary v might not
fully fall into this because you know he
does push i worked like my ass off in my
twenties and didn't really gary
vaynerchuk for those of you
maybe unfamiliar
i don't know i don't follow like carly
loves
garyvee anyway but yeah i mean garyvee
definitely does push the mess messaging
of
you kind of risk it all like you don't
really need to go to college exactly
which is of course funnels into a lot of
the mindsets of boys today but we see
with the mr beast and logan paul logan
paul had a situation where yeah he blew
up quick on vine so
went off with that but mr beast you even
see in his messaging that he's like you
know he just
i think he just stopped going to college
classes and just didn't tell his parents
and he was doing this entire youtube
thing he was every every dollar he made
off of his his youtube videos he was
putting back into future youtube videos
and again this guy's it's an out he's an
outlier which there there needs to be
those and a lot of people maybe embody
like oh that that is me next because
what happens with these content creators
is it feels super attainable like there
are these averages anybody can do it
yeah these average people
um and this happened to them because
they're especially being relatable right
that's how they
get their following yeah yeah and again
the whole risk it all thing uh you know
stop going to school and just put your
all into this and you see a success
what's her name rachel hollis um
who's older um than the gen z generation
but she wrote the book girl wash your
face has been like an influencer type
but she's
she said the quiet part out loud which
is probably true is a lot of these
influencers where she said something
like uh
basically went on a tire like i'm not
relatable like of course i'm not
relatable like i and she's like i'm rich
i work my ass off like this sort of
thing and the reality is a lot of these
like people like look what she said was
like pissed a lot of people off i'm not
defending what she said but the reality
is like to be this exceptional of a
content creator and this famous you
usually have to
you're probably working your ass off
behind the scenes and doing what you
treat like a media company like a
business like right um
yeah but a lot of people are like oh i
can you know just pick up a camera and
start recording that's definitely
happened a lot on the girls side who do
like lifestyle content have blown up
from literally just like yeah recording
their days and such
but um you know in my experience and
i think that people you should always be
building on the side you should have
things that keep are keeping you stable
and have your foundation and then you
can risk it slowly and surely once you
have
like there's proof in the pudding that
for example mr beast was creating videos
since he was like in middle school or
something and there was proof that he
was getting traction and then he felt
confident enough
to go full into youtube a lot of these
kids are just like oh i can do it like i
feel in my soul that this is what i
meant for and they just completely quit
what they're doing and have no solid
foundation no proof of of like
success one viral video today is not
proof of success like it was maybe five
to ten years ago when you can have one
viral video it really snowballs today
it's it's becoming a norm for everyone
probably has like one viral moment
online at this point not everyone but a
lot of people do more and more for sure
it's more and more it's tough to
monetize yeah and even i noticed like
you you know when i meet people or
something who follow me it's like it
feels more
friend like in the past it probably
feels more like oh like these people
notice me from online it's just like
your digital presence is becoming like a
portfolio and you should treat it as a
resume to get you into your ideal spaces
and careers and not look at it as like a
means to an end let me put everything
into it like do it on the side build it
up and you will get into your ideal
spaces
through considering it like almost like
a resume and a portfolio am i saying
this right or understanding you
correctly is
content creation should be a part of who
you are and what you do but not
necessarily your sole source of activity
and income yeah i mean
the average uh
lifespan or whatever of a a content
creator online i think it's like
uh what is it
it's like two years or something like
that i might that checks out
yeah so you see these people i'm i mean
and even people who were youtubers um
when i was young like i remember my
first favorite youtuber was fred like he
was just like crazy online he he's off
the map now in terms he makes youtube
videos differently now but it's by no
means what it was the attention economy
is hard to stay relevant you need to be
setting a foundation for yourself and
things that if it all goes away tomorrow
it's fine because
you used it in a way to yeah
get you into other career paths and
build something for yourself outside of
it because also uh people like to
dumb down what what it takes to be like
stay relevant on the internets like you
were saying there's a ton of hard work
that goes into it the attention economy
is hard and more and more people are
getting into it and um people are going
to find out quick even if they have a
good year it can all go away the next
year yes it's hard yeah
[Music]
you